cancer is a disease that occurs due to
mutations arising in our DNA in our
genomes occasionally mutations can be
acquired which disrupt genes which are
normally involved in how cells behave
and how they divide causing those cells
to abandon their normal functions and
become little factories producing more
and more and more copies of themselves
so cancer is really a disease of over
proliferation overgrowth of cells within
the body which can lead to all the
symptoms that were familiar with genome
sequencing is a fantastic tool which
allows us to actually find those
mutations and can tell us what caused
the cancer in the first place and also
perhaps give us some insights which can
help us to design new treatments for the
disease but in order to find the
mutations we need to know exactly what
the Tasmanian Devil genome looks like to
start with so we know where the cancer
is different so it was important for us
to sequence the genome of the normal
Tasmanian Devil as well as the cancer to
find out where those mutations are